hey everyone it's Michael Altos and
welcome to the Oder flows market
analysis for Monday August 21st 2017
stocks ended up kind of mixed I think we
had a light session later this week we
got durable goods and Janet Yellen on
Friday so he had just a marginal
marginal gain in the Dow today the crude
oil oil fell about a buck 47 50 and gold
was a little bit higher at 1300 I
thought the interesting thing today
interested in the sense of you know what
other people with a lot of money in the
in the game think is Bridgewater's that
Ray Dalio study was reducing risk
basically says technically reducing our
risk because he's concerned about
growing internal and external conflict
leading to impaired government
efficiency he said in a post on LinkedIn
you know take that for what you think
it's worth but you know I think the guy
because he's got shitload of money under
management and it's like one of the
biggest hedge funds out there so you
know the fact that he's basically going
to go into cash for a while is is kind
of to me at I don't say important but
you know interesting to note you know no
one wants to come out and necessarily
take a huge position you know if you
look at the chart today on the SPS you
know we ended up with basically a doji
candle pretty much unchanged and you
know and Friday as well so you know I
think that's that's indicative of sort
of the situation that we're in of course
you know being up near our contract
highs I mean even though we're you know
trading at 24 33 you know in our
contract Kaiser 2490 we're still
relatively you know on the upper end on
the upper end you know every time we
make new highs you always got people
coming out oh there's going to be a
crash it's going to be a crash so you
know some people you know they want to
protect what they got then and we'll go
to cash anyway enough of that get
through our disclaimer this presentation
is for educational informational
purposes only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision futures trading
contain substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all a more than the
initial and
spent risk capitals money that could be
lost not jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should can trade consider treating past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results again you
know just sort of going back up to you
know people calling for crashes you know
it kind of bothers me when I see James
Rodgers on TV all the time you know he's
predicting a crash well you know
guys lived in Singapore for how many
years I was living in Singapore at the
time and I would see him on TV all the
time and he'd be you know going back to
I don't know gosh mm whatever
he's been predicting a crash every year
he's predicting a crash always going
through the worst crash ever in my
lifetime you go back and you know watch
his videos on YouTube other than
predicting a bloom in China in the
run-up to the Olympics
he's been predicting a crash and you
know so it's like you know they put they
trudge them on and get them to talk
about how there's going to be a crash in
the market so I mean the guys predict
been predicting a crash for at least 10
years will it come yeah maybe it'll come
and then he'll say I was right that was
right well of all those years that
you're wrong I mean nobody wants to hold
them accountable for that but anyway you
know that's just that's just me talking
my nonsense so tools I use in this
presentation are the order flows trader
this is the volume footprint chart and
the Delta scalper now there are two
different things
some people come to me you get the Delta
scalper think it's going to give them a
full-blown volume footprint chart no
it's not
it's completely different than the order
flows trader okay
read the website read what the Delta
scalper is read what the order flows
trader is and I'm going to talk about
the transition bottles transition
indicator as well today so we've got a
full get a bunch of stuff so we'll start
with the transition it's really quick
transition is an order flow indicator
right that reads the order flow as it
comes in okay and it gives buy signals
it gives sell signals and this is it on
a mini dial 100 tick chart okay so you
got a few little trades here one two and
then boom you get this nice trade at you
know
588 was it do it rallies all the way up
to your area we get a sell at 650 you
know 655 that area get us small sell
sort of go side
weighs on you goes a little bit lower
than sideways get a few little buys here
that you know trailing your stop a
probably stop you out then you get this
beautiful nice buy here at 21 647 648
right here and it just shoots straight
up straight up all the way up into the
clothes here where are we right now you
know I'm not saying that you can hold it
over over to the next session but you
know this is you're pushing ready 100
points basically right here from the end
of the sessions and that's it so now is
every day as beautiful as this no but
you're going to get you know again this
is 100 tick chart it's a very fast chart
and you should be looking for a
short-term moves immediate moves you get
it here you get it here you get it here
and you know back here you get it as
well you know a small move there so
again it's picking up changes
transitions in supply and demand a bit
different though than the Delta scalper
Delta scalper picks it up by reading
different different information
basically so it's they're not the same
thing they are two different indicators
now the transition you know like to
Delta scalper run on an order flow chart
it'll run on a normal bar chart that's
why I'm showing you the bar charts a
little bit easier for people that are
new to order flow to get familiar with
it so anyway now let's just jump into
the order flow part of it if I can get
my mouse under control here okay so euro
currency again this is just this just
happen this is times it now it's like
9:30 Chicago time in the evening I just
you know looking at this this high here
at Trump Trump was talking some started
talking here we got this nice little
move up here 71 127 strong Delta on a
high and then 28 to 36 142 you know when
it starts you come up to the high and
then you start seeing the red bars you
start seeing you know some small numbers
and then go negative in the Delta it's
probably a sign that's marketers
going to sell off a little bit again
it's Asian time it's 9:30 at night
so it's you know depending on where you
are in Asia um it's it's 9:00 in the
morning here 10:00 in the morning rather
where I'm in and watch we sell off from
our high to your low it's very tight
range though but again you come up here
strong Delta why aren't we building on
it why aren't we going higher instead
you get a smaller Delta 28 then you get
a negative Delta minus 2 and then 36 at
this point you could be fairly confident
that the markets Python go a bit lower
and it does it goes from 32 down to 25
it's not big move it's just down here
this is your low actually at 24 and a
half but you got a decent little move
there now earlier in the session you
know there's a few interesting things
here similar thing where is it pick
those in the euro currency yeah it was
in the end but anyway you know let's
walk it back here and talk about this
okay so you had your high your initial
high last night at Sunday night at
around 20 to 10 o'clock it was 171 1780
we held that high all the way up until
6:00 in the morning started making this
how you got Rachel bombs low there you
got a divergence not necessarily any
strong reason to be selling you're
coming up here again you sort of got
this this high you know 51 you got a
high 150 build on it new high and then a
little bit lower high lower low here
with the negative Delta of just 30 and
then a new height with negative Delta of
59 next bar minus 250 again you know if
you're looking to get short it's
probably a decent short opportunity does
it really sell not really it only sells
off about five or six ticks just sort of
hangs around here until seven o'clock we
start rallying back up making the new
highs breaking out you got a stack
buying a balance there
you got a ratio divergence this one
fails on you you got the divergence here
negative Delta and the ratio it just
fails there's no other way to describe
it to sugarcoat it it just fails then
you get another ever ratio here no
divergence so that the positive Delta
Delta scalper right after it sells off a
little bit maybe about five or six ticks
rallies back up get up here you've got
another divergence no ratio and a
bullish ratio afterwards start coming
back up you see some trapped traders
down here on this sort of this fake move
lower doesn't happen doesn't go lower
then you get up here so you know again
it's 952 you've got already you've got
you know one failed divergence two
failed divergence and a few others back
here you know one two
so since eight o'clock until ten o'clock
you got a bunch of failed divergences
again which is a sign that we're
probably going to go higher you know at
this point when you start breaking
through these highs here you could
probably be pretty safe in trying to buy
these highs so if you buy this high you
know that's what 1 1833 it shoots up
I'll say shoots up but it gets all the
way up into 42 and a half up here at
this new high you know Delta scalper off
the high Delta scalper just goes
sideways on you then we start circling
around making a new high you've got that
excuse me getting up here towards this
high up here and look at this Delta
right 16 is kind of small negative 73 as
you're going up into new highs what is
that why is it negative 70 well you got
some decent buying in here 263 154 so
you've got some supportive buying
okay but still negative Delta then you
get up here and you got a small positive
Delta okay it's kind of confusing you
think and way or I got a small
Delta up here I got this negative Delta
of 73 here and then we start coming back
down if we break this area here where
you have this buying there's a chance
that we're going to go lower right look
for the selling to come in and then you
start seeing it minus 35 minus 158 minus
156 down here in the Delta
and boom we just we get a little
half-hearted pop-up and then we just
drop off you know we got this thin
volume in here one against thirty one
one against six you know three against
five you know six five three very thin
volume in here and we just you know we
start to get this little bit of a
head-fake
move back up and then it just drops out
there's nothing in here there's very
little transacting right here and we
just drop down from the you know 36 area
down into the 26 area you know which
puts us where we want out for the closed
for the day okay so this is the Aussie
dollar I don't really talk much about
the Aussie dollar but again it's it's
one of those contracts that just moves
it's like a slow-moving giant right it
just trends up it runs down trends back
up generally and if you catch some of
the movements then that's great because
again it's not something that says
volatile to say the Japanese yen or even
the euro currency said so we're coming
down here 5:11 we got a low we got the
Delta scalper giving you a signal right
you're coming down negative Delta
positive Delta here or small negative
Delta you know a little bit bigger
positive Delta so it's giving you the
sign in the Delta that it's starting to
expand and what do you do you rally up
from your low boom all the way up to the
highs again we got the stat bind
imbalances you're breaking out to the
highs and what happens up here at this
high you got the Delta scalper giving
you a cell and you know we come off in
the next bar then sort of circle back a
little bit towards the high of the day
you know before we come back down again
to a little bit lower low and go out for
the session but again it's one of those
things right the Delta scalper is
picking up these shifts in supply and
demand and on these slower moving
markets you know sometimes it's a little
bit cleaner the moves right you don't
have a lot of the choppy choppy stuff
that you get in say the you know in
contracts like the Japanese yen or even
even the euro currency now I want to
talk about this
as dakarai we're up here near ahyes
actually right now in the Nasdaq at 58
20 but during the day during the day go
back go back go back is a quite
interesting day if you're using you know
order flow so I have an order to start
here let's go back to 8:30 cache open ok
here
so is around 8:30 right in here so
anything ok you get these zero prints
which is bullish then here Delta scalper
again it's Petrina Delta you're making
this move down it's mostly negative
Delta now it's starting to pick up in
here Delta scalper picks it up
you get a nice move higher you know this
is it's a decent move from 57 that is 90
all the way up to you know 5800 yeah
Delta scalper cell just goes sideways on
you you still go higher higher higher
and you sell off at this high up here
again you got single print single print
single print which is a sign of price
rejection up here all these types of
these bars price rejection single print
single print single print single print
you know that stuff's important that's
why we put boxes around them to
highlight them to you and then what
happens on the move back up single print
single print single print you got ratio
ratio ratio three in a row you get to
pull back in here between these two
pointed controls and you get a little
bit of a rally then again you start to
come off here this is already only 855
in the morning okay get a delta scalper
kind of half-hearted next bar up next
bar down then we sort of stop you out
now a point of control on the extreme
this one fails you got a divergence
you've got a ratio point of control
extreme just go sideways on you know at
this low again you're getting some signs
in here you got Delta scalper giving you
a buy again another point of control
extreme you've got a bullish ratio you
got trap traders down here you got a lot
of volume going through down here
102 87 then you get a nice little move
up here from you know 5774 four and a
half area up to you know 80 before it
starts coming back down here boom boom
boom you can see the lower point of
controls red bars with lower pointed
controls is is a sign of a market that's
going to start heading lower nine
o'clock
you got divergence and a ratio you test
the low again single print single print
you get a little bit of a rally here
going on
you know from again from this 57 66 in
area up to 57 69 area point control
extreme again right down here on the
control extreme bullish ratio you shoot
up a nice little move there come back
down in Nasdaq is one of those things
you got to be fast on when you're
trading and eight when it's moving it
moves fast this is 9 24 9 24 9
24 9 24 so you got four bars in a minute
nothing scalper sell it doesn't work out
and you get you start running into this
area where is it over here ok so then
you get this by here write the Delta
scalper giving you this buy signal again
nice and move up from 62 all the way up
to in the 70s Delta scupper gives you a
sell nice little nice little buy signal
here comes up you run into this point of
control extreme right here 198 120 you
know there's a decent volume up there
stopping this move then it comes down
then you get a delta scalper by we shoot
back up again you know another delta
scalper sell is sell off
just go sideways on you sort of run up
into this area 1030 another Delta
scalper by here get a nice move up this
time again another delta scalper by
again another nice move up another Delta
scalper sell sells off succeed oh and
then there's a lot of there's some
trades that fail with the Delta scalper
but there's a lot of nice trades when
they work out there they were just
beautiful this is one doesn't work out
eventually it does but again I don't
like how it just sort of Peters around
here going into the cash close this cash
close five three o'clock but going into
the cash clothes he'll have to swing
high you get a little Delta scuppers
fell after the cash close you get a bye
and a nice little rally there okay um
what is this this is uh the five-year
note and again you know in the morning
3:00 in the morning you had ratio and
divergence does this failure it fails by
a tick up here and then you're getting
some bear signs again you getting
divergence you got that imbalance here
you've got a ratio and divergence right
here it sells off a little bit then you
run right into this point of control
extreme here eventually we rally back up
make this new hide and you get this bar
up here very odor this Delta - 4600
compared to all the deltas earlier you
see anything positive or negative
anywhere in around 4000 no that's a good
sign that's a very strong sign of
selling activity and if you're right on
your high you got the divergence you got
one two three imbalances next bar you
got the ratio do we sell off yeah a
little bit I mean it's kind of a tight
range most of the morning in the bond in
the fives actually you know so we go up
from 19 down to 18 for you sort of rally
back up again you hit that same high you
hit earlier a little bit less volume 194
where first time you got it
939 again that's also a better sign and
then you come off a little bit and in
the evening session right now we are
trading lower okay so really quick in
the is S&P four range chart this morning
and when you got here just after 7:00
just short seven rather you got a hot
you hit the high that you hit earlier
right here and Delta scalp are coming in
with a sell 7:14 we sell off you know
from this twenty six and a half period
all the way down into the twenty fours
actually eventually done twenty one cash
open or right around here is a cash
opening area so the offer on the cash
open you do get another little rally up
this Delta scalper this one fails right
here at a fifty two and you come down
you start making new lows you hit the
low bounce up you get stacks on and
balance going back down into the lows
again it's it's one of those things you
wanna I prefer it you know I put right
in here the first time you sort of hit
the lows rather than the second time but
anyway you know it came in here we did
make a new low by about a point and a
half he bounced up and then you start
running down in here again you got some
signs that looks like we're going to
start to rally maybe you know we got
some supportive buying in here Delta's
copper given a buy but then look how it
comes right back in balance imbalance
and multiple imbalances in this par one
two three and another one here so you
know even though you got some bullish
signs in here you got to be ready to
abandon those when you start seeing the
selling imbalances come in one two three
four five over two bars and what happens
is you come back down into the low to
make new lows now you're getting you
know Delta scalper up off this low here
you've seen some buying imbalances right
you don't see in selling imbalances that
you're seeing buying imbalances which is
better you know if you're looking to be
buying rather than after you buy all of
a sudden you're staring at a bunch of
sellin imbalances that's not what you
want you want to be looking at buying
imbalances so you know this buy here you
get it's a decent one decent opportunity
from seventeen and a half it trades all
the way up into the 20s before coming
back in here with
renewed buying to put you back up around
the 22 area again another Delta scalper
buy you know we got this little bit of a
move down you got imbalance in balance
in balance and then BOOM Delta scope and
giving you buy you got buying in balance
- balance buying and balance and we
start rallying back up now
you got a buying a balance here stacks
on imbalance right here no I like you
know these overlapping imbalances you
guys stack buying and you got stack
selling I like to get short these you
know what it's like this so what happens
is it comes right back binding balances
you know multiple you know to bind
imbalances in there and it's struggling
at this point it's struggling it this
moves not going to be happening pretty
soon I probably going to want to be
abandoned in it what happens is you just
go sideways even got a delta scalper
cell right up in here but it's just
going sideways sideways sideways Delta
scalper by almost at the same level at
that you have the cell we do rally back
up start making new highs here you got a
ratio no divergence then you got again a
new high you got positive Delta you're
just sitting up here you've got positive
Delta's all of a sudden starts changing
in here you've got almost a ratio it's
point seven nine I like point seven and
then right afterwards you got the Delta
scalper and again this nice move down
from 28 you know 27 and a half all the
way down to 23 is 22 area and you know
even a little bit lower then you got a
stack selling and balance here and
within the zone 1 2 3 4 4th bar you've
got to stack by an imbalance which is
bullish to me and what happens you know
this is like the opposite of what you
saw earlier right you had to stack mind
a balance in the stacks on a balance
they just went sideways this one worked
out again it got a little bit of a move
from the 25 and a half area all the way
up to 28 and a half area you got the
dealt with scalper given a sell now
you're going into the cash close and
then we close the day right now in the
evening session we are trading you know
we're trading higher right now back up
to the 30s 34 area
all right so Delta scalper I showed you
a bunch of examples on the order flow
chart let's take a look on the
obligatory bar chart 233 chart guy you
know the reason why I look at a 233
chart because some guy says it doesn't
work on a 233 chart and I tell him he's
wrong so let's take a look imagine here
going back to 8:30 8:30 here why are we
830 in here's got a sell small only a
nice little buy the cell doesn't work
out the cell works out the cell works
out is by not really it just fails
little move up here and then a nice move
down this one just kind of doesn't work
out here probably stop throughout this
one doesn't work out the cell doesn't
work out but again you're having these
small losses but really what you want is
then you get the nice winner so you're
willing to risk one pick to get back 5
ticks you know you could risk a little
bit you know here now you're just risk
in this area to get something like a
move like that you know there's going to
be periods where it sort of chops up
depending on how you're using your chart
settings you set up these are just the
default settings you can adjust it a
little bit to sort of filter out some of
these trades but again you know if
you're getting shorted 80 and you're
covering it back at 75 then you're
getting along at 75 cover it back at 80
that's 10 ticks right there you know
then you get a nice little buy here nice
buy here nice your little sell there you
know a nice buy there so again if this
is a 233 tick chart which for me is very
very you know the term is fast moving
but again you're using a 233 tick chart
you're probably going to be you know in
and out pretty quick you just look into
the next few ticks not necessarily for a
full you know full points or anything
like that
okay what else chart do I want here okay
I shouldn't get the right charts here
talk about the right thing
I wish my decks chart the axes one
minute charts on the Delta scalper okay
so you know in here 650 you're getting
short 12 120 130 right in here cells all
the cells off you stay short here from
again from you know 120 or 130 so where
are you you know done here's 100
points in the DAX do people you just get
one or two trades today you want that
trade you know this one this is by
workout mmm goes up a little bit go
sideways and comes down here probably
would've been stopped out somehow to
trail on your stop get this by again
this one doesn't really work out but
again that's fine because you just got
100 points right there that's two and a
half thousand euros well earlier okay
there was one other trade here this one
didn't work out just sort of went
sideways on you but again who gives a
if you catch in this move alright
you catching that move so you miss it
here and you get shortened here
you're still catching a monster move
that that's what you want as a trader
right you want to be risking five ticks
to get back you know a hundred ticks
that's you know twenty to one it doesn't
get any better than that on a daily and
intraday chart and oh no those are the
those are the type of trades that you
know most most traders would get you
know get a hard-on for excuse me so 987
tick charge in the euro and sorry in the
euro in the e minis okay so yeah sell
here doesn't really work a little sell
starts coming down then you met with the
body got a lot of PI signals down here
body goes up I just go sideways and boom
by right on the low 17 stay long stay
long all the way up you know up in here
which starts coming back down again so
this is
TenPoint so they maybe only get five
points out of it that's good enough I
mean I mean everyone wanted well I
didn't give me a cell up here well it's
because it's not you know the way the
order flow is being the way the market
is transacting there's no signal up
there instead you're getting down here
you're getting a lot of buy signals down
here so take your pick even if just
taking this one twenty two back you know
all the way up to 29 28 27 whatever you
know here you're taking the buy 21
against go back up in because it's 26 27
or again five points here five points
there you know that's that should be
good enough for for most most traders I
don't want that one
that's a different thing it's under
development
the Nasdaq charge so anyway I'll send
this now it's already running on a
half-hour so thanks for watching this to
learn more about overflow:visible
outside or close calm and go to delta
scalper if you're interested in delta
scalper you know delta scalpers is a
tool right don't think it's the holy
grail to trading there's no such thing
as a holy grail to trading I know I know
some people like to think there is and
they get upset when you know doesn't
when the indicator doesn't turn their
computer into it into a cash machine but
you know that's not was designed for
it's designed to help you in your
trading you know find little risk trades
so thanks for watching this and have a
good day I'm not sure if the ending got
recorded there or not but anyway to
learn more about trading with order flow
and the or flows trader software visit
order pose calm and if you're interested
in Delta scalper go to Delta scalper
calm its Delta scalpers a tool right
it's not the volume footprint chart it's
an indicator tool to help you find low
risk trades again you know it'll run on
a bar chart it'll run on a footprint
chart you know this is on a four range
mini Dow chart
which i think is for understand why
people like to trade for range bar
charts but on on mini da which you know
moves very very quickly sometimes but
again you know look at this you're
getting somebody buys here and i sell
there and i sell here giving you decent
signals right you got to manage your
risk I use stops it's not working out
get out I don't sit here say all I got
short here and I covered it back up here
no you've been getting out here
immediately right it's not working out
you know here you're getting long here
you try to write it as long as you can
you know learn how to manage your risk
and that's where a lot of traders fail
and they blame the indicator it's not
really then whether it's Delta scalper
or something else you know a lot of
traders don't use risk management and
then they blame the method of trading
that they're trading when it's their own
fault I mean as bad as it sounds that
that's to cut on is truth you know
really one of the most important parts
of aspects of trading is managing your
trade once you're in the trade knowing
when it's failing right it it's not like
getting short here and you're riding it
down writing it down if you don't don't
think you can get short here at 670 the
market is going to go to zero and you're
going to get 21,000 no you're not you
know when it starts giving you signs
that it's coming back up that's when you
get out right
especially on a four range chart that's
very very fast you got to react faster
you got to recognize when it's not
working out take your profits take your
losses get out look for the next trade
again don't sit here and think you want
to hold a four range trade on a mini
value and get short at 11:30 and hold it
up until 2 o'clock and get angry when at
you know 2:30 or 3:00 it stops you out
for a loss when it's spent the last you
know 3 hours in the money but you know
that comes with experience and you know
the more you trade the more experience
you get so again thanks for watching
this have a good day and I'll see you
tomorrow